Logistic regression is one of the most
basic forms of regression modelling.
It's part of the family of generalized
linear models, or GLM, for short.
Which basically means that the formula
is very similar to that of
a linear regression.
However, since the target
variable is in categories
instead of a continuous
numeric variable,
the target variable has to be
modified to fit this GLM formula.
Let's go back and revisit that
formula from lesson one for a moment.
Patrick presented the linear regression
formula that you see on the screen here.
As a reminder, in this equation
y is the target variable.
Beta naught is the intercept or
the baseline value and b1 or
beta 1, beta 2, beta 3, all the way to
beta n represents the coefficients for
the different variables.
x1, x2, x3, all the way to xn as well.
So let's compare this formula to one
of the logistic regression formulas and
yep, there are actually
more than one of them.
Let's first focus on the right
hand side of the equation.
The right hand side of the equation is
actually identical to that of a linear
regression.
Where again, beta naught represents
the intercept or the baseline value.
Beta 1, beta 2, beta 3, all the way
up to beta n again represents
the coefficients of the variables x1,
x2, x3 again all the way to xn.
Now, what is going on the left
hand side of the equation?
Well don't be scared, this is clearly
where the logistic regression separates
from that of a linear regression.
But actually it is
conceptually very similar.
What we're trying to do is find
the probability of P which represents
an outcome.
Like, in our example P represents the
probability of yes, they will redeem.
The natural log is also in this
equation to deal with the binary nature
of this problem.